The Highlander franchise is a series of stories
based around one compelling, original idea:
a fight between the world's Immortals, who
have secretly walked among us since the dawn
of time.
The original movie revolves around Immortal
Connor MacLeod, from his youth in the fields
of medieval Scotland to 1980s New York City,
where the last Immortals are being drawn by
destiny to fight each other to the death.
As we work our way up to the remake set to
be helmed by John Wick co-director Chad Stahelski,
we're catching up with the untold truth of
Highlander.
It came from the bathroom
"From the dawn of time we came, moving silently
down through the centuries…"
Spoken sonorously by Sean Connery, who played
the Immortal Ramirez, the film's brief introductory
monologue tells you everything you need to
know.
As it turns out, Connery recorded the iconic
intro to the series in his bathroom, which
is why it echoes so much.
So the next time you hear that powerful intro,
just know that it's Sean Connery standing
half-naked in his vacation home, holding the
script in one hand, the phone in the other,
trying not to bump his knee on the toilet.
That's great acting, people.
"How revolting!
Achoo!"
There are still unreleased Queen songs
"Here we are!
Born to be kings!"
The value of Queen in the original Highlander
can simply not be overstated.
It's impossible to imagine the movie without
the band's music.
But despite how heavily Queen's music features
in the franchise, there was never an official
soundtrack.
Instead, many songs from the movie ended up
on unofficial releases and Queen's 12th studio
album, 1986's A Kind of Magic.
While the big numbers are all there, there
are Queen songs in the movie that have yet
to make it onto any album.
The most notable omission being the band's
cover of "Theme from New York, New York" as
it plays in the lead-up to the climactic final
battle.
"If I can make it there…
I'll make it anywhere!"
To date, only about 40 seconds of the song
has been released.
Allegedly, Freddie Mercury hated singing it,
which is why it's never been released.
And also, it sounds more than a little ridiculous.
Christopher Lambert's peculiar accent
One of the most enigmatic and charming things
about the original Highlander is Christopher
Lambert's legendarily weird accent, which,
just like the actor, is impossible to pin
down.
"Christopher motherf---ing Lambert.
The lord of the apes!
Lord Raiden!
And once lord of Diane Lane.
The guy had sex with Diane Lane!
Multiple times!"
The movie even references his unusual accent,
intentionally or not, when a police officer
notices MacLeod's inflection and pointedly
asks him where he comes from, netting the
cheeky reply,
"You talk funny, Nash.
Where you from?"
"Lots of different places."
This was less of an intentional acting choice
than simply a happy accident.
Reportedly, the accent came as a result of
Lambert's limited grasp of English at the
time of filming.
Though born in New York, he was raised and
started his acting career in France.
At the time of Highlander's filming, his only
prior English-speaking role had been an inarticulate
Tarzan who's only just learning English.
Not really an excuse for a guy who's been
around for hundreds of years, because it doesn't
get much weirder than this.
"You have better things to do than lie there
on your ass."
The blind Highlander
Christopher Lambert must have been completely
lost during the filming of these movies.
In addition to being very iffy with English,
Lambert couldn't actually see much of what
he was doing either.
Lambert suffers from myopia, a disorder that
blurs his vision, and filmed all of his work
without his much-needed glasses.
It's one thing to just talk with your eyes
closed; it's a very different, way-more-dangerous
thing to conduct hand-to-hand combat.
In addition to nearly taking a tooth out of
co-star Michael Ironside's head during filming
of the sequel, Lambert got his own finger
split open because he couldn't see a swing
coming.
It's kind of remarkable that it took a whole
movie and a half before Lambert was injured.
Couldn't they just let the Immortal wear glasses?
There's a recut sequel
What is there to say about Highlander II:
The Quickening that hasn't already been spat
by Roger Ebert?
"By the way, all of this insanity could have
added up to something that would have made
a great, bad movie!
But Highlander 2 is so crazily put together,
you get the impression that a lot of the key
scenes were just never filmed."
A movie so bad it has to be seen to be believed,
the puzzling follow-up received generally
terrible reviews.
No longer coming "from the dawn of time" as
ageless enigmas, Highlander II "reveals" the
earthbound Immortals to actually be...aliens!
From the planet...Zeist!
And sets the action on an Earth artificially
darkened by a man-made solar shield.
Which is a plot goofy and cartoonishly evil
enough to be used by The Simpsons a few years
later.
Because it was so bizarre, Highlander II was
essentially ignored in continuity.
But there was another, later cut that aimed
to improve the sequel's quality.
Marketed as the "Renegade Version," the newer
cut makes the movie better simply by cutting
out a lot of the weirder elements that made
the theatrical release so awful.
It's still not a great movie, but it's not
one of the worst ones of all time, either.
Weird cameos
It's possible that you might know Highlander
better from the long-running TV show, rather
than the movie that spawned it.
"In the end, there can be only one.
May it be Duncan McLeod."
Starring Adrian Paul, the series ran for six
seasons throughout the mid-90s, a precursor
to other relatively cheesy fantasy series
of the time like Xena: Warrior Princess or
Hercules: The Legendary Journeys.
The series exists mostly as a cultural artifact,
featuting wild celebrity cameos from the likes
of rock star Joan Jett, porn star Traci Lords,
and Rowdy Roddy Piper, among others.
It's one of the main reasons to watch the
series today.
Because it's one thing to see a guest star
recite lines on Law & Order — but it's a
completely different thing to see, say, Scottish
singer-songwriter Sheena Easton swinging a
sword around.
"Damn you, Duncan McLeod."
There was another TV show
Barely remembered now, 1998 saw the release
of a short-lived spinoff to the series called
The Raven.
Starring former Miss America Elizabeth Gracen,
the series followed the Immortal thief Amanda
and her ex-cop buddy as they solved crimes,
and sought redemption for past sins.
General franchise fatigue caused The Raven
to never really catch on.
Rumors of production difficulties, and a reported
tryst with Gracen and former president Bill
Clinton years earlier, killed the series.
The Raven ran for just one season...
"There can be only one!
Ungh!"
...ending the Highlander franchise's live-action
presence on TV after a seven-year run.
There was an anime
There's a far fringe to the Highlander franchise
where the continuity starts to get even weirder:
like the Highlander anime movie, which actually
scored positive reviews.
Called The Search for Vengeance, the film
was written by Highlander series alum David
Abramowitz, which gives it a level of fan
credibility that many of the live action sequels
can't even claim.
It's also probably the only fringe media in
the Highlander universe that might be worth
your time.
Meanwhile, Highlander: The Animated Series
is best left forgotten, as is the clunky game
based on the cartoon.
The 1986 game wasn't much better, either.
And in 2001, an online MMO was in development,
but eventually cancelled.
Yet another game, developed nearly a decade
later for next-gen systems, was canceled in
development, leaving behind only a remarkably
unpromising trailer.
The moral of the story: let's not dismiss
the remake, okay?
Could it be any weirder, worse, or off-base
than what's come before?
Probably not.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!